[BEEPING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Welcome the first episode
on the Baseline Data,
ML, and AI quest.
This quest of all
introductory-level, self-paced
labs is intended for
the complete beginner
in Google Cloud.
You'll get your
first-touch experiences
with a subset of the
Google Cloud Services
that provide tools for working
with big and small data,
machine learning, and artificial
intelligence services in Google
Cloud.
After you're done with
all the labs in the quest,
you'll get this badge to
recognize your achievement.
You can add the badge to
your social media accounts
and resume to let others
know about your new skills.
The way the show works is
you'll watch a short video,
like this one, where
I'll be introducing you
to a lab on Qwiklabs and give
you a quick overview of what
you'll learn.
I'll also point you to
additional resources
where you can find more
information about each topic.
Once you're done
watching the episode,
you can head on over to
Qwiklabs and do the lab.
You can watch all the videos
and then do all the labs,
or you can work on the labs
and then pop over to the videos
to find additional resources.
This is your quest,
and you can follow it
in the best way that suits you.
You don't even need to
do the labs in order.
I'm excited to get
started, so let's
move on to our next
episode and first lab
in the quest, BigQuery--
Qwik Start Using the
Web User Interface.